jack flaherty whose numbers are very
very good 7-0 and you look at the
hyundai pitch arsenal for flaherty and
the fastball has the normal flaherty
velocity change-up slider curveball
especially the slider to me has been
kind of his wipeout pitch he in spring
training he was underneath it a bit and
again spring training a long time ago
but it took him a while to get that feel
back and it is
all the way back popped up orinato
bald territory
and makes the catch
newman has reached bay safely in 17 of
his last 19 starts in the 2-2 pitch
ground ball
sosa to his left
out number two
the 2-2
oh yeah
oh yeah
right hook to the chin
tommy edmond will lead things off for
the cardinals we'll try their hands
against trevor cahill
and tommy smokes one
out to deep right
it is off the top of the wall
lead off double tommy edmond paul
goldschmidt a career 301 hitter 15
doubles against the pirates and
goldschmidt hits it a ton out to deep
right fail
one hopper off the wall edmond will
score
goldie trots into second base
with a double to score tommy edmund
one-nothing st louis i love the way
goldschmidt hits the ball to right field
he hits the ball hard to right field now
yadier molina
you see him bail out
well how about cahill rebounding to
strikeout arenado and molina the
cardinals in the first round tying run
is over at first base with a legal off
walk in the second inning for jack it's
will craig now
and that is hit to renato for the out
and the one-two pitch to defoe
ground ball hit to the right side gold
schmidt will take it himself steps on
the bag and they're going to walk perez
to get to trevor cahill
check swing and he did go it's a
strikeout and the second tonight
for jack flaherty midway through two
cardinals on top the bases are loaded
for jack flaherty
he's been wild
so far in the ceiling that sinker
nowhere close to the zone
and rafael freitas the
pirates head athletic trainer given a
long look at trevor cahill and he's
going to come out of this ball game so
i don't know if there's something that
had been lingering with him or if
there's something new
tonight but cahill is going to depart in
the second inning of this ball game
dwayne underwood jr will pick up for
trevor cahill who has left this game
with an injury jack flaherty will hit
with a 1-0 count and the base is loaded
he is lying to right polanco makes the
catch
good base running by bader tagging up
and also williams on a line drive to
right they advance and it's two nothing
top of the lineup tommy edmond
edmond up the middle base hit
two runs will score
four nothing cardinals and tommy is two
for two
we talked about the importance of
production at the bottom of the lineup
get on base and then turn the lineup
back over again and then have your
guys that can flat out hit at the plate
and tommy edmonds one of those guys i
just love his at bats it's a lot of
balls hard whether they're line drives
on the ground in the air underwood has
allowed 10 of 11 inherited runners to
score this season all three tonight and
the one-two pitch to the cardinal first
baseman
in the center field in a base hit
here comes tommy edmond he will score
and it's five nothing st louis
goldschmidt is driven in two tonight
he's up to 24. nolan arnotto with
runners at first and second arenado
slices one into the gap in right center
carlson will score
goldsmith to third
and nolan orenado drives in his 31st and
it's six to nothing cardinals
molina is at the plate now struck out in
the first he's the ninth man to bat in
the inning
and he bounces this ball to third
backhanded by defoe throw to second for
one to first double play was a nice turn
defoe to fraser to craig and will craig
the first baseman will come up the 2-2
hammered out to deep left field but
williams
is under it and he'll make the catch
we'll take that back-to-back free passes
top of the order now and tommy edmond
and will craig with a great play at
first the minor league goal glover with
a major league play michael perez the
left-handed batting catcher
here's a swing and a miss perez goes for
a curve in the dirt the strikeout is the
third for flaherty two outs in the
fourth inning and now their pitcher
dewayne underwood junior comes up for
the first time o2 and a strikeout we
have one out for yani or molina carlson
at second goldschmidt at first
and this ball in the air
to right polanco
will make the catch runners will hold as
the throw comes all the way into third
and about three hops the batter is
harrison bader he's walked and grounded
out underwood and a swing and a miss
high fastball the strikeout head to the
fifth inning it's cardinal six pirates
nothing there's kevin newman in the 01
[Applause]
outstanding
takes a hit away from kevin newman not
much time to react on that play by
edmundo sosa and he helps out his
pitcher
just a snap step to your right and dive
and you better have the glove in the
right spot and he did
a great play
but this is polanco he's walked and he's
reached center fielder's choice and the
next pitch is hit high in the air and
polanco says he got it you just watch
him drop the bat and
clear the deck with a cannonball to
right gregory polanco
it's his fourth home run of the season
my goodness gregory polanco he was up
there sitting on fastball in got it
and he turns on it the big man
with an exit velocity about 106.
towering fly ball here is a lead off man
now edmond the 1-1
edmond rips it out to right field
polanco over and makes the catch two
runners tag up one will score that's
williams and that makes it a 7-2 st
louis lead here's dylan carlson runners
at the corners and he takes it the other
way
that's a base hit
that's run number eight
eight two cardinals
one ball two strike delivery swinging a
miss
foul tip that strikeout for flaherty is
his sixth this would be pitch number 105
coming up
swaying and a miss ends his night with
strikeout number seven ryan reynolds is
coming
to the plate faces loaded nobody out
we're gonna
gotta have a big inning here
mandatory
softly hit try to stay out of two yep
that gets a run in but
the first out of the hitting polanco
homered is last time up
hard hit and through that'll get in
frazier
and reynolds going to try to take third
he will on the base hit by polanco he's
driven in three tonight and don't count
out the bucks they've got the tying run
out on deck now here in the seven this
will be ill demar of argus finch hitting
first pirate at bat and he makes a name
for himself
rbi hit on the first pitch he sees
vargas singles in reynolds the pirates
will bring the tying run-up after being
down six entering this inning first and
third with two down and the switch
hitting wilmer defoe the o2 pitch
swaying and a miss he got him keeps it a
three-run st louis lee two outs nobody
on and a 3-2 pitch to frazier
lined caught again sosa
his second diving catch what a play
around the former cub vargas walks to
the plate he'll bad left-handed two down
and one to go ends it with a strikeout
strikes out three in a row to finish off
the pirates in a two-game sweep and the
final of eight to five